Você sabia que o cérebro dos homens
encolhe mais rápido do que o das
mulheres com passar tempo? Pois é. Um
estudo enorme da Universidade de Ozlo,
publicado na revista PNAS, analisou mais
de 12.000 exames de ressonância
magnética e descobriu que o cérebro
masculino perde volume cerca de 2% ao
ano, enquanto o feminino perde em torno
de 1,2%.
Ou seja, os homens têm envelhecimento
cerebral mais acelerado. As regiões mais
afetadas são áreas ligadas à memória e à
percepção, justamente aquelas que a
gente precisa manter afiadas com o
tempo. Agora, veja que curioso, mesmo
com esse ritmo mais lento de
envelhecimento, as mulheres ainda são
mais diagnosticadas com os Heimer. Isso
mostra que o cérebro envelhece de
maneiras diferentes e que fatores
genéticos hormonais até de longevidade
entram nessa conta. Então, a mensagem é
clara: Manter o cérebro ativo com boa
alimentação, sono estímulos mentais é
essencial para todo mundo, mas os homens
em especial precisam ficar ainda mais
atentos a esse risco. Yeah.